how do you guys feel about just the
different like themes of like the
restaurants you find here because i feel
like in japan there are more like you
could there you there are more ways that
you can find just like really uniquely
done like little cafes or restaurants
more than i've seen in like basically
where where i came from or even london
to me i think more so bars there's more
themed bars yeah yeah yeah exactly a lot
of bars bars and cafes mostly yeah yeah
you look at some of these bars and you
think how the [ __ ] do you stay in
business right because some of these
bars are tiny it's like you you think of
a bar at least in like the uk and
america and you think it's a it's a
building you know it's it's it's a it's
a building with a dedicated room with
tables and chairs and that is the bar
and some of these bars are just a
countertop you're talking about the one
we found the other night yeah yeah yeah
yeah the one that was literally the size
of a hallway yeah that was so weird guys
yeah building do you want to tell the
story yeah so we basically it was after
the the really short toilet bar right
and we were like oh we're feeling good
so you know it's been a while since the
three of us had like gone out to go
drink and stuff like that so we were
like let's let's go to this other place
in tokyo called
which has like a lot of like small
hidden bars and clubs and stuff like
that all over the place and by hidden we
mean like there's one road that is just
like
covered there's like buildings that have
like you know maybe 20 30 bars in it
yeah over like six stories or something
yeah yeah they're like maybe some like
six to ten story buildings and they just
had like that the signs were from the
top to the bottom like stacked and it's
just like 30 40.
so we just like let's just go into one
of them and the one we went into
was like really like pristine and like
very like shiny and very like chic which
is weird because outside of it it looks
like a normal apartment building yeah
yeah and like really grinding you get
off you get off the elevator i think it
was on like the fourth or fifth floor
you get off the elevator and it's just
this dark hallway
yellowish yeah the doors of this
horrible any other country
any other country that is like a floor
where you would get stabbed yeah exactly
but yeah there was like three or four
bars that were open this was like let's
just go into one of them we went in
really pristine like silver chic looking
thing and there was this like
old lady at the end yeah uh that was
like you know drinking something really
expensive but yeah the size of this
place was maybe what four people could
sit at the bar yeah i mean i think about
six because i remember there was lady on
one end and we were on the other end and
there were like two seats between us and
the lady yeah and that's all it could
see
and that's it and the width was
literally the size of a hallway yeah
yeah exactly
exactly and they had three people
running this bar for a bar that can seat
six people there are just as many bar
men behind the bar as there were people
sitting at the bar exactly it was really
awkward we walked in there and it was
like this woman
quite elderly woman in like a kimono
yeah drinking like dom perignon clearly
like a really important yeah and these
like three bartenders were like all
caring for her like laughing at
everything she was saying yeah and then
we walked in and they kind of went like
what do you guys want
and we sat down like
they were like fine and they gave us
like a bog standard uh beer from a a
glass that cost us 20
yeah to be fair though we did eat like
all of their complimentary snacks yeah
hey they brought out a lot of stuff i
don't know what the [ __ ] snack that was
but it was so good whatever it was like
they were these were like your average
bar snacks they were like premium stuff
like dried fruits and stuff yeah and
every time we ate them they immediately
refilled it and i started feeling really
bad because like we must have it like i
saw them like opening new packs
like reluctantly pouring more snacks for
us
but it was just like the atmosphere was
like really weird it wasn't a weird yeah
it was like because then when the
elderly woman left like two of the
bartenders followed her out and yeah
yeah
they might not have even worked at the
bar they might have just been like her
personal attendance yeah there's like
two there's two of them like one of them
was in like a tuxedo yeah he was quite
elderly as well yeah and he looked like
like the [ __ ] butler from overlord
and then we were like they'll come back
but they never never came but they all
left at one point they left us in the
bar yeah just like alone for like five
minutes and we were like
this is only in japan would they leave
the bar with the customers still in
there just to make sure this like rich
customer can go and do yeah yeah so
strange so strange it was very weird but
like do you how do you think some of
these bars do stay in business if if
they do very rich customers that are
regulars i know there's a big like
regular cut like uh what's the word
regular um
yeah yeah i think it's very
common to find a bar you like and just
only go to yeah yeah yeah
i like to just constantly bar hop and
just see what else yeah yeah me too
because like some of these bars that you
know you kind of like discover like this
one but this is like one of like
basically every time we go out and
discover a new place we go into one of
these kinds of bar where it's like every
time we go in the bar is like almost
empty or there's just like that one
person
sitting uh sitting in the corner like i
remember when we went out with jan as
well it was just like the three of us
and one person in the corner and it's
just this one bartender who i saw it's
just like
it's true he's just chill he's just
enjoying his job which is just a delight
to see and you know i get it that's why
like it's it's so weird to me that
tipping culture isn't a thing and yet
bars like this are are able to stay
in business because i can't imagine bars
like this staying in business if there
wasn't a tipping culture right yeah
because the drinks were expensive but
they weren't like ridiculously expensive
to the point where one or two people can
in my mind at least run the entire
run the entire bar economy and keep it
afloat so it just it just it just blows
my mind that's really nice yeah i have a
mate actually who owns a bar in saitama
all right um yeah and uh like because uh
my my hairdresser at the time was like
friends with them so i got to norm
through that and he was just like oh and
i was just like curious because i was
like how many customers do you get
because it's kind of like inside first
of all which is like far away from right
so there's less of a population to you
know for customers but i'm like it was
also in like a really like hidden area
right like kind of similar to the one we
went to and i was like how many
customers a night do you get and he was
like oh like three or four on average oh
my god and i was like are you like how
long are you open for and he's like oh
like two days a week i'm like and this
is your only job and he's like yeah all
the other days that i'm off i would go
skiing oh and i was like how
how just
like where does this money come from and
he literally just said like i get three
to four customers but it's usually the
same three or four customers that just
keep coming back and are there literally
from bar open to bar close right just
because like they're his mates and this
is like the only time they get to hang
out with him while he's working kind of
thing right
kind of cool with sad at the same time
yeah i mean he's enjoying it and you
know it's still around and everything
but it's just like really fascinating
how you can just
make that as a living yeah that goes
into like the other aspect of japanese
culture that is very prevalent where
they they like predictability they like
the same thing yeah yeah they want to
know what's going to happen i guess for
bot owner and customer it's good right
because yeah you get to go to the same
bar every day you get to know what
you're going to get and then if you're
the owner it's like great i know my
customers i know they're going to come
and yes xxx yeah because i i do think
that like that's the really cool
part of bar culture in japan is that you
like there are so many small little
places and there's like places that you
would never be able to do in any other
country or at least in any other country
that i've lived in
um because that kind of like that kind
of business model just wouldn't work
yeah you know you have to have that
dedication of your regular customers and
even
there has to be like a it's like kind of
like a symbiotic relationship right that
the customers always need to be there
and the customers come back knowing that
they are the ones that are keeping this
bar in business and they are the only
ones but i guess what i wanted to know
is like how do you establish yourself
with that
how much how did you how did you like i
just i think it's literally just word of
mouth at that point the turnover was so
fast yeah like i know that restaurants
and and bars close and open very fast in
japan yeah i imagine that a lot of them
unfortunately fail yeah i know like
ramen stores are like incredibly
expensive to start and operate oh it's
also incredibly competitive yeah yeah
exactly you can get ramen at any street
corner yeah and then you just get
destroyed by by uh
yeah you either get destroyed by each
round or like a
like mcdonald's
of the mega corporations well it's like
yeah i don't know it's i literally think
it's just like a mate like you know if
one of your mates is like i'm going to
start a bar in ex location yeah you'll
be like oh i'll come and check it out
one night and then you go tell your
mates about it and then yeah that
friendship forms and then that symbiotic
relationship forms and then
if it keeps going well
it'll keep growing out but i mean with
how quick it you know with a bar is
there much expenses to start out with
apart from obviously getting the
location i guess all the alcohol
is quite expensive you need to like i
mean the bars the bars we went to some
of them were in like an apartment
building so they were based they were
basically just someone's someone's
apartment right but the way they
renovated this bar it looks [ __ ]
great you know there are so many small
touches in every bar we go to so i'm
sure a lot of it was also spent on
renovation just to make it look like a
bar
yeah yeah i think we went to two bars
that night i remember the second one was
a lot more themed but the first one was
very chill really nice yeah and i think
i think they were reasonably priced
because this guy would spend like 10
minutes making a drink yeah yeah like
could he have been faster yeah probably
but it was nice watching it's like i
feel like that's part of the experience
you're in these like cool bars like you
just get to watch the guy just go ham
yeah yeah do little things just make
something cool and then i taste it and i
don't really taste much difference in
other drinks but that's not the point is
that it feels nice it's the experience
it's the experience that you've been
like yeah he's making your food yeah
yeah yeah i don't know it's really nice
it's like drinking weather spoons has
like trained my mind into being like i
need to get this drink as fast as
possible
you mean you're like i order like mojito
and they'd better just be serving it in
a [ __ ] jug because otherwise this
time i'm waiting to get this mojito it
could be used to like drink something
else you know so just
going into these bars which are more
chilled out is such a like different but
nice experience because you'd only
normally go to these bars in the uk if
you had like a [ __ ] ton of money to
spend on i also feel you don't spend on
drinking so i personally don't go into
those bars to get shit-faced no no you
can't really yeah i mean you can if
you're there for long enough right
you're ordering stuff that's like easy
but it's at the same time it's like you
know if you're going to pay for that
experience and that like atmosphere
actual atmosphere then just like go easy
on your drinks right just go slowly it's
kind of hard because the atmosphere
doesn't really make you feel like you're
like drink drink jacob yeah just take
your time take your time just relax
let's just talk it's like let's just
talk i'm so really thankful that i speak
enough japanese to be able to do those
bars like no pressure yeah cause those
bars don't require that much yeah so i
feel like if you if there's any reason
to learn japanese probably just learn
super basic stuff so you can go to those
bars because if you don't speak any
japanese they might be like also it's a
really it's it's it's also a really good
place to practice japanese that's true
as well that's true um because i every
time i go bar hopping i you know i get
to speak more japanese than i would
normally and the
bartenders are normally well it's kind
of their job to be way more
understanding and very and come it's
their job to interact with the customers
basically yeah exactly if you're going
to talk to the bartender they're not
going to be like
they might they might they pretty much
they're really nice i've never had i've
never been to one of those bars where
the bartender's been like rude right no
no they're always super nice yeah always
interesting well they wouldn't be in
business if they weren't that's true at
the end of the day it's customer service
there's only like six seats they better
be nice to every [ __ ] customer that
comes in yeah they can't be they can't
pretend to like oh what was that you
were saying like go to a different
customer but you're the only one there